hey everyone it's nurse Sarah with
registered nurse rn.com and in this
video I want to demonstrate how to apply
and remove the stat lock securement
device for patients with an indwelling
Foley catheter so let's get started so
we're going to get our stat lock device
and take it off here and just open up
the packaging
so here's the actual device itself this
is going to go on the inner thigh of the
female now for male patients the
securement device is usually placed
either on the top part of the thigh or
the lower abdomen with the male's
genitals positioned toward the abdomen
however you always want to follow your
facility's protocol for securement
device placement and then there's a skin
protectant pad which is going to be
applied prior to actually putting it on
so let's put it on so the first step of
what you want to do before you place
this on the patient is that you want to
put this actual catheter in the retainer
because we don't want to put this on the
patient's skin and then clamp it shut
it's not going to feel too good to the
patient so we have the arrow see this
Arrow here it's pointing towards the
insertion site that is where we want to
go so we have the arrow pointy we're
going to take the bifurcation of the
catheter and there's this little part
right here hanging off this white part
it's going to just set in between this
catheter right here see like that it's
right there and then we're going to
close it shut by pressing these little
lines right here we're not going to
press in the middle we're going to press
those lines and it's nice and in place
now we want to find a spot to put our
stat lock so make sure the patient's leg
is completely extended and we're going
to go on the inner thigh of the female
and we want to go about right here but
we want some slack in this catheter line
we don't want too much or too little so
according to the manufacturer they say
pick your spot and then go back about an
inch and that is about where you want to
go so you want to keep note of this
because this is the area you're going to
clean we're going to clean this whole
area with alcohol prep and then with
skin prep so I'm going to put my fingers
here just to remind me I'm taking my
alcohol prep and I'm cleaning this area
I'm going to clean an area that's even
bigger than that
stat lock device we want to remove any
dirt and grime that is on this skin and
then we're going to let that dry
completely now that that has dried
completely I'm going to take the skin
prep and I'm going to clean that whole
area again but this is just protectant
to protect the patient's skin because
these stat locks stay on the skin for a
while especially if they're going to be
having an indwelling catheter
and you want to change these stat locks
out according to your facility's
protocol it's usually about every seven
days and while you're waiting for your
site to dry you want to put your
initials in the date for when you
inserted this so the person behind you
will know when to change this out now
that it is dry we're ready to place the
stat lock on the skin so to do that we
are going to pull back one side of the
adhesive
and just place that on the skin rub that
down
then we're going to pull the other back
off
put that on the skin and then
put it down
and again confirm your arrow is pointing
toward the towards the insertion side
to remove this device you're going to
need several alcohol prep pads first
what you want to do before you actually
remove this adhesive is that you want to
unclip this catheter from the clip in
the device so to do this if you ever
forget it has instructions right here
you're going to
push the sides in like that and it just
pops off very easy then we're just going
to lift this up carefully and just lay
it right here and it shouldn't move and
it'll be safe and secure there and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
take our alcohol prep and it tells you
here on the device removed with alcohol
so you can start on either side you want
I'm going to start right here so you can
see it and I'm going to get this wet
with the alcohol
and what this does is it neutralizes
this adhesive that is on the patient's
skin so look it's already starting to
come up so we're going to pull it up
we're just going to keep cleaning the
skin and cleaning
the sticky part of the device and it
just easily comes up we're going to do
the same here
and just pulling slightly here as we
clean the patch and the skin and it just
peels right off this is so much more
comfortable for your patient then coming
over here and just ripping it off it
could literally rip off that top layer
of skin
so there it came off now what we will do
is dispose of this